Ecco qua Ah sì aggiungiamone un altro
pochino stai facendo Non si vede bene
l'ultima goccia del liquame siamo però
non mi spingere
ce l'ho detto
Cosa ci fate qui
No cosa ho fatto ma nessuno
[Musica]
Ma
cosa è successo
[Musica]
stai bene
Aiutatemi Grazie
Come stai tutto più bella delé e voi Voi
pensate di tutto il tempo
tutto a terra le mie pozioni la mia
scoperta Halloween
scoperta Ma di che cosa stai parlando
anche molto brava brava brava
è una pratica che coinvolge la scienza
la chimica e la fisica degli ingredienti
creando così formule e pozioni magiche
e anche se questa volta è purtroppo non
ha funzionato tanto
però vedete ci sto quasi arrivando alla
mia scoperta
che tipo di scoperta che di che cosa
stai parlando
Eh credo veramente e penso che ve lo più
avanti ehm insomma eh Ma voi che cosa
stavate facendo
niente lo stavamo facendo niente Ti dico
la verità volevamo capire che cosa stavi
facendo tu sembravi un po' sospetta Come
ho detto prima Vitale è Anita non posso
dirvelo è un segreto ancora Eh sì Ehm Ma
voi avete scoperto qualcosa Beh in
realtà abbiamo trovato qualche indizio
ma ci servirebbe un po' più di tempo
dobbiamo indagare ancora un po' non
abbiamo ancora capito bene di Kate
creatura si tratta e soprattutto non
l'abbiamo trovata ancora sta calando il
sole ehm vi inviterei a restare qua
questa notte Anche perché se la creatura
dovesse ritornare potrebbe succedere
proprio stanotte questa notte
però io mi sento molto stanca adesso
e penso che andrò a dormire ma voi
incredibili liberi di come se fossi a
casa vostra e perlustrare mangiare
dormire fate quello che volete io
veramente vado a dormire Sono troppo
stanca ormai quindi vorrà dire che
rimarremo qui questa notte sì È l'unico
modo per risolvere questo caso in più
lei ti sembrava piuttosto sicura che la
creatura si presenterà questa notte
non mi fido del tutto di fiamma Anche se
lei ha detto che è perché un Alchimista
ma non lo so c'è qualcosa che non mi
convince No no infatti è molto strana
Non so se fidarmi oppure no vabbè
prepariamoci per stanotte è meglio se
facciamo qualche ricerca sulle creature
magari troviamo anche qualcosa per
difenderci
[Musica]
che sonno
Tu che stai facendo
Sto cercando informazioni sulla creatura
ovviamente
non sei spaventato neanche un pochino
ma sono spaventato per un motivo non
abbiamo neanche mangiato oggi ma neanche
un biscotto
c'è la minaccia di una creatura e tu
pensi a mangiare
bisogna essere in forza per affrontare
una creatura bisogna anche mangiare no
Il problema è che non sappiamo ancora di
Che creatura si tratta Anche se mi sono
fatta un'idea ma non sono sicura ancora
devo ancora continuare le mie ricerche
Ma hai mai pensato che magari tutto
questo è una trappola architettata
appunto da fiamma
Certo che ci ho pensato e ho pensato ad
altre 15 cose solo che ancora c'è
qualcosa che non mi quadra
insomma È come se mancasse un tassello
per farmi dire sì Sicuramente siamo alla
creatura oppure no Sicuramente non è
infiamma la creatura quindi non possiamo
ancora accusare nessuno È vero hai
ragione
cos'era quel rumore
è quello che tempo fa
la creatura A meno che non è infiamma
che si sta facendo uno scherzo ma mi
sembrava una creatura molto grande a
giudicare dal rumore che ha fatto ok È
arrivato il momento di entrare in azione
[Musica]
c'è nessuno da dove proveniva il rumore
destra sinistra davanti dietro Secondo
me veniva da lì a destra Eh credo
proprio di sì vabbè Mi fido di te allora
abbiamo a controllare Mi raccomando
si sentono solo dei cani per ora
E che è positivo o negativo
per ora positivo se sono solo cani Ok
Cosa dovrebbero essere oltre cani volpi
Ti ricordo che stiamo cercando la
creatura non degli animali selvatici Ok
ok
Che strano Abbiamo sentito un rumore
Fortissimo poi usciamo fuori di casa ed
è completo silenzio Infatti sembra non
sia nemmeno successo ma non è che ce lo
siamo immaginato non credo a meno che
non sia fiamma con la sua trappola
Magari è la teoria della Trappola di
fiamma e lei ci ha fatto credere che sia
una creatura fuori per chiudersi fuori
di casa farci dormire al freddo ma come
già non abbiamo mangiato e più dobbiamo
pure al freddo Ma ti sembra normale non
lo so È tutto strano Non c'è nessuna
creatura qua mi sembra ho sentito il
rumore
da dove dirà
Oh no dobbiamo continuare a proseguire
in questo terreno così buio desolato
E va bene dai Continuiamo la ricerca
mi è appena venuto in mente un'idea
se è una trappola di fiamma
vuol dire che fiamma sta facendo
qualcosa che non vuole che noi vediamo
cioè che lei ci ha mandato qua fuori
perché lì doveva fare qualcosa dentro
Così noi possiamo stare qui e non vedere
che cosa state facendo le idee una delle
sue pozioni le sta preparando apposta
per avvelenarci mentre dormiamo non lo
so qualcosa
meglio se ritorniamo in casa allora e
magari controlliamo se fiamma sta
veramente dormendo Ok buona idea però
non facciamoci scoprire Questa volta
ho cambiato tutto aiuto aiuto aiuto
aiuto
Apro questa volta abbiamo questa porta
aprendo Oh Fammi provare a me Fammi
provare dai dai Apri
non si apre sbrigati sbrigati
Che cos'è lo Slime
l'hai visto anche tu vero Spegni la pila
ok
però
[Musica]
[Applauso]
mi sono anche spaventato Spegni questa
luce Spegni ci potrebbe vedere si
riconosce arriva qui subito e la
creatura più grande che io abbia mai
visto più potente che abbiamo sentito
una cosa grossa no non possiamo
direttamente scappare chiunque
scapperebbe davanti una creatura così
grande e mostruosa Ma che dici Non
possiamo scappare c'è fiamma da sola la
creatura potrebbe prenderla e se invece
fosse fiamma La creatura Come ti ho già
detto è vero ma non possiamo esserne
sicuri che cosa facciamo rischiamo che
la creatura si sbrani fiamma perché
abbiamo il sospetto che sia lei no
Effettivamente no per cui non fosse lei
anzi
non vedo più la creatura potrebbe essere
entrata dentro casa dentro casa c'è
fiamma Oh no andiamo andiamo a salvarlo
forza ho bisogno di aiuto
Ecco Questa è l'altra entrata è meglio
entrare da qua sì e speriamo che fiamma
abbia lasciato le porte aperte
altrimenti come facciamo ad entrare
andiamo a controllare
[Musica]
questo salotto è un po' desolato Sì è
vero Beh ci sono altri dubbi che mi
servono che dubbi perché è fiamma abita
in questa casa gigante vuota ed è anche
solo
lo sapevo Era la creatura non ne siamo
ancora sicuri al 100% quindi
ho visto qualcosa là dietro
la porta dietro la scatola dietro la
[Applauso]
No non credo proprio i lupi mannari poi
hanno il fatto incredibile
Per fortuna che questa mattina mi sono
lavato
e c'è da ridere se non sai come mi sente
subito
[Musica]
Ascolta Mi è venuta un'idea
non ci troverà quel pallone e quando ci
troverà puntiamogli subito le torcere in
faccia e proviamo ad accecarlo una volta
che lo accecheremo scapperemo da quella
parte va bene Sei sicuro che sia una
buona idea No però dobbiamo provarci ok
pensieri di pronto
[Musica]
[Applauso]